Buenos días, buenas tardes.
Soy Steve y tengo el placer de
conversar con Andrea de Spanishland.
Conversar en Español, por supuesto.
Y vamos a hablar sobre el aprendizaje
del Español en el continente Americano,
en Europa y en el mundo.
Si te gustan mis vídeos, por favor,
haz click en la campana
para recibir notificaciones y para registrarse.
Bueno Andrea, después del Inglés,
me parece que el idioma
más estudiado en el mundo
es el Español.
Claro que en los Estados Unidos es el caso,
pero también en otros rincones del mundo.
Tu enseñas el Español a través
del internet, en tu canal de YouTube.
Vamos a dejar un link con el
enlace en la caja de descripción.
¿De dónde vienen tus suscriptores
¿De qué paises?
Andrea: Pues primero, hola para
todos y gracias Steve por invitarme.
La mayoría de nuestros estudiantes
que llegan a nuestro programa,
como dijiste, es por internet, es en línea.
Vienen de 4 paises.
S: Bueno.
A: Principalmente Estados Unidos,
después Canadá,
después de eso Inglaterra y luego Australia.
S: Ah bueno.
A: Asi que la mayoría de nuestros estudiantes
tienen el inglés como lengua materna.
Pero también tenemos
estudiantes de Alemania, de Suiza,
incluso tenemos algunos estudiantes
en Japón, en Brasil poquitos
Y también en otros paises.
S: El español es un idioma que
se habla en muchos paises,
con acentos diferentes.
De vez en cuando, con vocabulario diferente.
Empezamos con esta cuestión:
El "tú" y el "usted".
¿En qué país y en qué situación,
se debe usar el tú o el usted?
A: Bueno, generalmente siempre
hablamos de una distinción entre
el "usted" como formal y el
"tú" como informal, verdad?
Eso todos lo sabemos, y si
aplica en general a todos los paises
pero la verdad es que el uso
de ellos depende mucho del país
y de la región.
Por ejemplo, si tu vas a Mexico
y empiezas a hablar con alguien
en la calle, en el aeropuerto,
como que las personas esperan
que tu uses el pronombre usted.
Pero en Colombia esta bien usar tú,
casi que con cualquier persona.
Aquí utilizamos usted, con las
personas en un nivel de autoridad.
Pero digamos en Bogotá,
en la costa de Colombia,
todo el mundo utiliza "tú" con
las personas que no conocen.
Y te digo algo curioso, en mi
ciudad Bucaramanga - Colombia,
la mayoría de personas
utilizan usted con todos.
Es decir, yo utilizo usted con
mi mamá, con mis hermanos,
y con mis amigos.
Es el inverso, es el opuesto.
Aquí en mi ciudad utilizamos
usted con las personas cercanas
y tú con las que no conocemos.
S: Muy interesante.
Es un poco como el você
en Portugués, en Brasil.
Que se parece un poco al "vos", a la
segunda persona mas formal plural.
Pero hay ciertas regiones me parece, en
Brasil, en dónde se utiliza también el tú
pero no en todo el país.
A: No sé mucho sobre Brasil,
porque ni idea con el Portugués,
pero sí sé que en toda
Latinoamérica pasa lo mismo.
Qué el uso del tú, el usted, y
el vos que es otro pronombre,
cambia de país a país y
también de región a región.
S: Por ejemplo, la situación en Argentina.
¿Sabes un poco como se
usan el tú y el vos en Argentina?
A: Lo que sé es que en Argentina la
mayoría usa vos y casi nadie usa tú.
Y usted es para situaciones
formales, como muy muy formales.
Eso es lo que he sabido.
S: Bueno, muy interesante.
Otra cosa, a mi me parece que el
español si comparamos por ejemplo
el inglés, el portugués, el francés
para mi las diferencias de pronunciación
son menos grandes en el Español
que en el Francés o en el Inglés.
Por ejemplo, la diferencia
entre el Escocés, el Australiano,
es más grande desde el punto
de vista de la pronunciación
que la diferencia entre el
Mexicano, el Colombiano
aunque en el Español tengan la Z.
Pero las vocales son más o
menos las mismas, me parece.
¿Qué piensas tú sobre esta cuestión?
A: Tu estas diciendo que si el español
que se habla en Mexico, en Colombia
y en todos los paises, que
si cambia un poco el acento?
S: Se cambian menos vocales.
Cambian menos que por ejemplo en Inglés,
o en Portugués o en Francés.
El francés de Quebec y el francés de Francia.
Hay mayor diferencia de pronunciación,
para mi que no soy nativo del Español.
Pero me parece que es mas
similar la pronunciación en México,
a excepción de Chile u otros paises
que también tienen una
pronunciación muy particular.
Pero es mas similar
que el Francés o el Inglés.
A: Claro que si, yo creo
que estoy de acuerdo contigo
que las vocales son muy muy
similares, sin importar el país.
Porque precisamente el Español es un idioma
que se caracteriza por ser muy abierto.
Cuando hablamos abrimos mucho la boca, no?
Porque los sonidos vocales son muy asi.
Entonces creo que si,
que son muy similares.
Claro que de acuerdo al acento del país,
va a cambiar un poco.
Como lo dices en el caso de Chile.
Chile, es una cuestión diferente.
Pero si, la diferencia
que si hay es por ejemplo,
entre la consonante,
la letra "Y" y la "LL".
Eso si cambia un poco de acuerdo al país.
Por ejemplo, en la mayoría
de paises de Centroamerica
ellos pronuncian la "ll" por
ejemplo del verbo "Rain", llover
Yo colombiana digo llover.
Como si fuera una Y.
"Yo soy Andrea" y
"Llover", lo mismo.
Pero en Mexico si dicen como "iover".
Entoncés es más con las consonantes.
S: ¿Y en Argentina?
A: Sh-over
"Sho me shamo Andrea
y va a shover hoy"
Si, en Argentina la "LL" es
casi como si fuera "sh" del Inglés.
Como "she".
S: Si, muy interesantes las
diferencias entre los acentos en Español.
Es más una cuestión de consonantes
y menos una cuestión de vocales.
Como en inglés que por
ejemplo Up, los diptóngos que hay
yo no sé, en Escocés, en
Australiano, en el sur de USA,
hay una mayor diferencia de pronunciación.
Es la misma cosa en Quebec, en la
pronunciación del Francés en Quebec.
Otra cuestión, bueno hablando de
diferencias de consonantes, es la S.
Porque hay ciertos paises donde no
se entiende la S en America Latina.
A: Si, es... bueno.
Hay muchas cosas en cuanto a las consonantes
y las terminaciones de las palabras.
S: Si.
A: En cuanto a, por ejemplo,
todos los lugares que sean costa
las personas tienden a no
pronunciar la S al final de las sílabas.
Al final de las palabras, pero
realmente al final de cada sílaba.
Por eso decimos que se comen las S.
Entoncés para los que aprenden
español, escuchar a alguien de la costa,
siempre va a ser más díficil.
Siempre van a tener más problemas con eso.
Tambien la "R" la tienden
a pronunciar como una "L".
S: Ah bueno.
A: Por ejemplo, en Colombia hay
una ciudad que se llama Cartagena.
Cartagena.
Pero, los que viven
allá le dicen "Caltagena".
S: Bueno, interesante.
A: O cortan ese sonido.
Y también otra diferencia
es que en España, la letra C,
por ejemplo, el nombre
"Cecilia" ellos dicen "Thezilia"
"Thierto" "Graciath"
Es como si fuera la "th"
de Thanks, en inglés.
Pero eso solo pasa en España, sabes?
Porque aquí en Latinoamérica
no hacemos ese sonido.
S: Yo no sé si es verdad, pero
parece que en el sur de España
en Andalucía, de dónde venian
gran parte de los inmigrantes originales
de España, tampoco se usa tanto la "Z".
Puede ser esta la razón por la cual
en America Latina no se usa tanto la Z.
Pero la pronunciación
de "Z" como Zinc en inglés,
existe en el arabe, existe en el griego.
Entoncés es posible que
hayan tenido una influencia,
porque había colonias de Griegos
y también la influencia del Arabe.
Yo no sé, pero no es tan
raro como se puede pensar.
A: Ah, interesante.
S: Si, pues hay un mito
acerca del Rey de España,
que dice que tenía problemas para
pronunciar la S y por esa razón es que la
gente utiliza la Z, pero no es verdad.
Es una forma de pronunciar
"th", que existe en Arabe,
como decía, en el griego,
y otros idiomas también.
A: Yo nunca había escuchado
lo que acabas de explicar,
pero tiene mucho sentido.
Y si es verdad lo que dijiste, de
que en algunas regiones de España
aun hoy en día no se
hace ese sonido de "th"
sino es como el "Cecilia"
normal de Latinoamerica,
y eso si que lo he leído, que las
personas que vinieron a conquistar
como que no tenian ese "th" y
por eso nosotros no lo tenemos.
Pero lo de la influencia de
los arabes y esa cuestión,
no lo sabía y creo que quizás
sea cierto, no?
S: Es posible, es posible.
Yo he aprendido mi
español, bueno en España,
viajando en España hace 50 años.
A mi me gusta la Z, porque
yo he visto que muchas
personas de América Latina cuando
escriben en castellano confunden
la "S" con la "C".
Y por ejemplo, para escribir no
sé, una palabra donde hay una C,
utilizan la S porque es el mismo sonido.
A: No, no, continúa.
S: Por eso, por ejemplo,
en el Italiano la C es "Ch"
entoncés es muy lógico
que en otro idioma Latino,
haya una diferencia entre "C" y "S".
Entoncés para mi es lógico,
pero es una cuestión de costumbre.
A: De costumbre, si.
Tienes toda la razón,
tienes mucha razón en lo que dices
y eso es muy cierto.
Como aquí en Latinoamerica
la S y la C, suenan igual
la gente tiende a confundirse y cuando
estan escribiendo no saben si es S o es C.
Por ejemplo, la palabra "Position"
Posición, es primero con S y luego con C.
Pero si tu la escuchas
como yo la digo es "posición"
mientras que un español
diría "Posizión", cierto?
Entoncés si, es interesante eso.
S: Si, es interesante.
Okey, ahora vamos a cambiar de tema.
La mayoría de tus estudiantes vienen
de paises de idioma de lengua Inglesa.
¿Por qué quieren ellos
aprender el español?
A: ¿Por qué quieren aprenderlo?
Hay 4 razones principales
y son bien interesantes.
La primera, es gente
jovén que quiere viajar.
Que en sus vacaciones quiere viajar,
principalmente a México, a Costa Rica
a Panamá, algunos a Colombia.
Por la cultura Mexicana que
esta tan impregnada en USA,
la gente tiene mucha curiosidad por México.
Entoncés muchos solo quieren
poderse comunicar cuando están viajando.
En el caso de los estudiantes de
Inglaterra, viajan mucho a España.
Entoncés quieren aprender para comunicarse.
Esa es la número 1.
La número 2, son personas
que aprenden Español por placer.
Es un hobby para ellos.
Son gente que estudio Español
en el colegio, en la universidad
y nunca más tuvo tiempo y
ahora estan jubilados y quieren
aprender más, sólo por placer.
La número 3 es bien interesante
porque tenemos varios estudiantes
de California y de Florida,
y de New York, que tienen
familiares, sus padres, sus abuelos,
son mexicanos, cubanos,
puertorriqueños y resulta que
ellos nunca aprendieron la lengua.
Entoncés quieren comunicarse
con sus tíos, con sus primos,
quieren conectarse con la cultura o
estan casados con un hispanohablante.
Y la última razón, son principalmente
abogados, médicos, enfermeros,
fisioterapeutas, personas que
hacen terapia del lenguaje, profesores,
que tienen pacientes, estudiantes
o clientes que hablan español
y lo necesitan para su trabajo.
S: Muy interesante.
Y digame ¿Cuáles son las dificultades del
idioma que encuentran estos estudiantes?
¿Qué es lo más díficil?
Algunos puntos de dificultad que
tienen estos estudiantes con la lengua.
A: Bueno, yo diría que con todos
los idiomas los estudiantes van a tener
dificultad para entender lo
que la gente dice y para hablar.
Eso es para todos los idiomas.
Pero para español, yo diria
que hay 3 dificultades principales
con las que todos luchan.
La primera es la pronunciación,
precisamente de las vocales.
Y precisamente de estos sonidos
consonantes que hemos estado discutiendo.
Una palabra como por ejemplo "Europa"
o "aureola", como la de un ángel.
Tiene que abrir la boca,
hay 2 sonidos vocales juntos,
eso es algo que es muy
dificil para los estudiantes.
Por supuesto la "R", perro, carro
Entoncés la pronunciación
de las vocales yo diría es díficil
porque no están tan
acostumbrados a abrir mucho la boca.
La segunda cosa es la jerga,
que no sé con tu experiencia
pero seguramente has notado
que hay muchas palabras diferentes
en cada país.
El español es muy amplío,
y casi cada país tiene su
propio diccionario de expresiones
y de nombres de cosas, verdad?
S: Sí.
A: Entoncés es algo que confunde
muchisimo a los estudiantes,
porque pueden aprender conmigo
español de aquí de Colombia,
y van a Nicaragua y estan perdidos
porque todas las cosas
tienen un nombre distinto.
Y la número 3, son por
ejemplo, el modo subjuntivo.
S: Ah, si.
A: Que realmente no es que
exista en Inglés.
El hecho de que si estas expresando
una emoción, una duda, una posibilidad
tienes que cambiar la
conjugación del verbo.
Eso es muy díficil para ellos.
También cuestiones de la
gramática, de cómo funciona la lengua.
Por ejemplo, el imperativo.
No sólo hay una forma en Inglés,
resulta que en Español hay 3.
Porque "Tú", "Usted" y "Vos".
"Por" vs "Para"
"Ser" vs "Estar"
Yo diría que esos son
como los puntos más díficiles.
S: Bueno, vamos a terminar con esto.
Pero diría que yo he entendido
que la pronunciación en Colombia,
es la pronunciación más
neutral, más fácil de entender,
que puede servir en cualquier
país de América Latina o de España.
Y efectivamente, yo te escucho y
tienes una pronunciación muy muy clara,
muy fácil de entender.
Yo creo que sería una buena idea
para mis seguidores, estudiar contigo.
Por supuesto.
Y segundo, yo creo que esos
problemas con el Español,
esos errores potenciales no impiden,
no hacen que alguien no
pueda comunicarse en el idioma.
Se pueden cometer errores,
esos cuatro puntos que has dicho.
Pero sin embargo puedes
entender y puedes comunicarte.
La gente no debe tener
miedo de cometer errores.
Normalmente va a continuar
cometiendo esos errores,
hasta que finalmente la
cantidad de errores va a disminuir.
A: Exacto.
No va a desaparecer quizás,
pero va a disminuir mucho.
Quería decir algo rápido,
lo que tu dijiste es cierto.
He leído muchos articulos que
dicen que el español de Colombia
es el más facil de entender,
pero también quiero clarificar
que no es en Colombia en general,
que solo es en unos lugares
específicos de Colombia
y es el interior del país.
Principalmente de las ciudades de
Bogotá, Bucaramanga, mi ciudad, y Medellín.
Tú empiezas a irte al campo,
a la costa, al sur, a los llanos,
al lado donde esta el Océano
Pacífico, no vas a entender nada.
S: Okey.
A: Entoncés, es Bogotá, Medellín
y Bucaramanga, que son fáciles.
S: Bueno, pero de todas maneras
pueden aprender contigo el acento de Bogotá
y mejorar su nivel de español.
Muchas gracias por la
conversación y hasta luego.
A: Muchisimas gracias
a ti por invitarme.
Espero que todos hayan aprendido algo hoy.
A: Chau
S: Chau, adiós.